[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies guten abend und
herzlich willkommen den sport hat für
sie noch mit lehmann einen schuss am tor
von mir die themen des tages
richtungsweisendes urteil vom
bundesgerichtshof die milliardenschweren
comex aktiengeschäfte sind strafbar
der staat kann sich unrechtmäßige
gewinne jetzt zurückholen chemie unfall
mit folgen nach der explosion in
leverkusen sind die menschen besorgt und
auf spielplätzen und gärten lagern sich
rußpartikel ab und deutscher
doppelerfolg in der dressur jessica von
bredow wandel holt erneut gold bei den
olympischen spielen isabell werth
gewinnst silber dazu comics
aktiengeschäfte was erstmal technisch
klingt ist der wohl größte steuerbetrug
der deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte
heute hat der bundesgerichtshof
bestätigt die deals waren kriminell und
nicht das ausnutzen eines
steuerschlupfloch wir reden hier von
mindestens zwölf milliarden euro um die
der fiskus insgesamt geprellt wurde das
ist etwa der haushalt des
bundesfamilienministeriums grob gesagt
wurden aktien mit und ohne ex dividende
so oft hin und her gehandelt dass die
finanzbehörden keinen überblick mehr
hatten und eine einmal gezahlte
kapitalertragsteuer mehrmals erstatteten
christian decker mit den einzelheiten
sie haben sich strafbar gemacht diese
beiden börsen händler aus london hatten
comex geschäfte mit organisiert und
waren die ersten die im märz 2020 vom
landgericht bonn verurteilt wurden
sie erhielten bewährungsstrafen wegen
steuerhinterziehung und beihilfe zur
steuerhinterziehung
der bundesgerichtshof hat ihre
verurteilung nun bestätigt damit ist
klar
comics geschäfte sind grundsätzlich eine
straftat
der senat bewertet das verhalten als
strafbare steuerhinterziehung eine
gesetzeslücke die nur ausgenutzt worden
ist lag gerade nicht vor das hat der
senat ausdrücklich klargestellt die
angeklagten handelten auch mit
steuerhinterziehungs vorsatz bei comex
handelt es sich um geschäfte mit risiken
aktienpaketen rund um den termin der
dividendenzahlung die papiere schopmann
so trickreich hin und her dass das
finanzamt nicht mehr folgen konnte
dabei wurde die nötige steuer nur einmal
bezahlt am ende aber vom finanzamt
mehrfach zurückerstattet das heutige bgh
urteil ist enorm wichtig denn es schafft
klarheit für die anderen
gerichtsverfahren aber vor allem auch
für die ermittlungen die zur zeit laufen
jetzt ist klar comex geschäfte sind eine
straftat
das bedeutet für die vielen hundert
personen gegen die aufwändig ermittelt
wird das ihnen am ende eine verurteilung
drohen kann und was das geld betrifft da
hat der bgh hatte klar gemacht der staat
kann sich die unrechtmäßigen gewinne aus
den comics deals zurückholen
sowohl von einzelpersonen als auch von
den beteiligten banken blicken wir auf
corona der inzidenz ist weiter leicht
gestiegen um zu verhindern dass sie
immer stärker nach oben geht wenn jetzt
die politischen stimmen lauter die
fordern dass sich alle ungeimpften
reiserückkehrer innen testen lassen
müssen
schon ab dem ersten august könnte das
pflicht werden eines lanz gehe über die
diskussion auf den letzten metern eine
generelle tests pflicht für
reiserückkehrer bloß ab wann und für wen
geplant ist ein negativer test egal von
wo und mit welchem verkehrsmittel man
ein reist laut bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten bereits ab sonntag
gestern aufgabe ist die persönliche
zusage des kanzleramts des
kanzleramtsministers dass man es
schaffen wird bis zum ersten acht und
auch die zusage vertrauen wir die wir
auch ganz wichtig denn die
ursprünglichen pläne das erst mitte
september die neuen regeln greifen wenn
ihr völlig unsinnig denn zu dem
zeitpunkt in die ferien bereits vorbei
söder macht druck aus berlin heute keine
bestätigung kein dementi es soll noch
rechtliche bedenken gegeben
stand der dinge ist es gibt einen
laufenden abstimmungsprozess innerhalb
der bundesregierung und in würde das
ergebnis werden sie ganz bestimmt sofort
auf dem laufenden halten
die zeit drängt im norden gehen
demnächst die ferien zu ende
auch spd und grüne begrüßen eine
testpflicht für urlaubsrückkehrer wir
haben bereits gesehen dass
reiserückkehrer eben die infektion dann
auch in kitas und schulen wieder rein
gebracht haben und deswegen ist eine
testpflicht für reiserückkehrer die
jetzt nicht bereits geimpft worden sind
absolut notwendig ich halte es nicht für
möglich dass wir grenzkontrollen
einführen aber wenn eine solche tests
nicht verfügt wird gibt es ausreichende
möglichkeiten das auch zu kontrollieren
und das würden wir auch mit unseren
möglichkeiten gemeinsam mit der
bundespolizei tun
der kampf gegen korona vor zwei tagen
hat das rk ii in einem brandbrief
gewarnt die vierte welle habe bereits
begonnen
die inzidenz müsse weiterhin leid
indikator für die pandemie bleiben auch
thema bei der vorgezogenen
ministerpräsidenten konferenz mit der
kanzlerin
in knapp zwei wochen und beide länder
treffen wird es dann auch darum gehen
wie man noch mehr menschen zum impfen
bewegen kann
märz die hälfte der menschen in
deutschland ist jetzt vollständig gegen
korona geimpft für eine weiterreichende
immunität in der bevölkerung reicht das
nicht
und die impfbereitschaft nimmt achse
konrad hat für sie den aktuellen stand
beim impfen zusammengefasst fünf
impfungen in der sekunde
auch wenn sich das tempo in den
vergangenen wochen halbiert hat es geht
immer noch deutlich vor an mindestens
einmal geimpft sind in deutschland
mittlerweile gut 60 prozent der
bevölkerung und mehr als die hälfte hat
bereits den vollständigen impfschutz
am höchsten ist die impfquote bei den
über 60-jährigen knapp 74 prozent haben
die doppel impfung exakt 50 prozent sind
es bei den 18 bis 59 jährigen
bei den 12 bis 17 jährigen ist die quote
11,4 deutlich am meisten im stoff wurde
in den impfzentren gespräch
bei den bundesländern ein klares
west-ost-gefälle hinsichtlich der
einfach kämpften spitzenreiter bremen
und das saarland schlusslicht der
thüringen und sachsen
seit beginn dieses beitrages wurden
statistisch übrigens 250 menschen in
deutschland geimpft
welche rolle spielen impfquote um sieben
tage incidents bei einer möglichen
vierten corona welle mehr dazu gleich in
einem zdf- heute live um 19.30 in der
heute app auf youtube und auf facebook
nach der explosion in einer
müllverbrennungsanlage in leverkusen hat
die betreiberfirma keine hoffnung mehr
die fünf vermissten menschen noch lebend
zu finden
zwei mitarbeiter kamen durch die
detonation bereits ums leben
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt und die
große frage ist auch wie giftig und
gefährlich war die rußwolke ralph
goldmann berichtet die spielplätze sind
gesperrt kaum menschen auf den straßen
leverkusen bürrig direkt neben dem
chemiepark die anwohner sind
verunsichert sie sollen keine partikel
über die schuhe ins haus tragen
hautkontakt vermeiden und obst und
gemüse aus dem garten nicht essen
wir warten jetzt erstmal auf die
untersuchungsergebnisse bringen werden
und werden aber jetzt momentan aktuell
so lange aus dem garten ja nix verzehren
ich bin beunruhigt ob alles in ordnung
ist ob das noch mal passieren kann ja
wie gesagt man hat angst die rußwolke
war gestern der bericht stadt nach osten
gezogen über das ruhrgebiet bis dortmund
die öligen partikel hatten zum teil die
größe einer euromünze das
landesumweltamt geht davon aus dass bei
den brand der chlorhaltigen
lösungsmittel dioxine und andere giftige
und krebserregende stoffe wie pcb und
furane freigesetzt wurden in welcher
konzentration ist noch unklar
zwei menschen starben 31 wurden verletzt
noch immer werden arbeiter vermisst wir
müssen leider davon ausgehen dass wir
die fünf vermissten
nicht lebend finden vier von die kugel
von die vermissten sind currenta
mitarbeiter ein fünfter mit der kollege
ist von einem externen unternehmen
die kriminalpolizei will sich morgen vor
ort einen überblick verschaffen die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt inzwischen
gegen unbekannt proben der rußpartikel
werden derzeit im landesumweltamt
analysiert die ergebnisse sollen ende
der woche vorliegen
und wir bleiben in nordrhein westfalen
nach der flutkatastrophe dort und in
rheinland pfalz ist die tat zahl der
toten gestiegen
auf insgesamt 181 773 menschen werden
noch immer vermisst
dort wo einmal häuser standen gegen
trümmer entsorgungsunternehmen gehen von
mehreren hunderttausend tonnen sperrmüll
aus zusätzlich zu dem müll der ja
ohnehin anfällt viele abfälle sind wegen
der ausnahmesituation nach unsortiert
wohin damit fragen sich viele kommunen
dort fabia und saskia schüring berichten
der teddy und alles andere muss weg und
zwar schnell
schlammige abfall liegt überall wie hier
im sauerländischen altena
schon gar nicht nach es ist wahnsinn was
sie momentan torgefahr
das hört und hört nicht auf das ist
wahnsinn
hier stinkt und schimmelt es der müll
ist eine gesundheitsgefahr
und er versperrt straßen die müllfahrer
werden sehnlichst erwartet
das auto 10 und materialien rauf
schaffen wo man mir jagen wir alles dem
fuß darauf zu israel oder
müllverbrennungsanlage kommenden
unterbrochenen lastwagen mehrere
hunderttausend tonnen abfall sind wohl
insgesamt nach dem hochwasser angefallen
dem schatten die entsorger vor ort nicht
wir müssen uns überregional organisieren
wir zehn teams und techniker standorten
für die abfuhr zusammen und wir müssen
inzwischen lagerkapazitäten
verbrennungsanlagen auch außerhalb des
landes nordrhein westfalen mit
einbeziehen
das land hilft die müllentsorgung zu
koordinieren und appelliert an die
bürgerinnen und bürger
jeder soll sich jetzt mal in den
nächsten wochen überlegen sein sperma
vielleicht im keller zu lassen damit die
hochwasser geschädigten kommunen eine
möglichkeit haben ihren sperma
tatsächlich zu entsorgen
denn der hochwasser sperrmüll hat jetzt
vorrang und es wird dauern
ihn zu beseitigen die zerstörung nach
der flutkatastrophe ist dreh- sich die
hilfsbereitschaft aber auch tausende
freiwillige wollten sofort helfen
aber manche wurden direkt wieder nach
hause geschickt die straßen unpassierbar
die koordination der hilfe
mangelhaft inzwischen läuft es besser
auch im weinort dernau besonders schwer
getroffene kreis ahrweiler angela hatte
und julia schröter berichten
der neue mittel ahrtal hier ist wie an
so vielen orten an ein ende des
aufräumens noch gar nicht zu denken
helferinnen und helfer werden weiter
dringend gebraucht und sie kommen jeden
tag ihre verteilung ist immer besser
organisiert in der laufen alle fäden bei
marco zusammen
wir haben einfach ein paar helfer mit
funkgeräten ausgestattet die scouten
jetzt sozusagen sprechen die anwohner
des iran wo die probleme eben wirklich
auflaufen melden dass durch und die
ankommenden helfer die verändern ihren
trips eingeteilt und losgeschickt
auch diese freiwilligen hat marco
vermittelt sie befreien den keller eines
hauses von kontaminierten schlamm mit
einer kette in handarbeit
doch ganz egal wie schmutzig die arbeit
ist die stimmung ist gut berichten zwei
die sonst als flugbegleiterinnen
arbeiten
das ist interessant nach dieser ganz
langen corona zeit wo die die leute so
in die isolation getrieben hat ist hier
ein spread eine gemeinschaft das ist
einfach ganz treuen gut richtig gut man
glaubt wieder an die menschen ja auch
der transport ins flutgebiet
funktioniert inzwischen gut helfer
packen ihre privatwagen am shuttle platz
an der a61 von dort geht es morgens mit
kleinen und großen bussen ins ahrtal
wir haben also in der woche auch letzte
woche am tag um die 1500 bis 2000 leute
die weit runter fahren und natürlich am
wochenende dementsprechend mehr weil
natürlich auch dann berufstätige dann
zeit haben nach dem arbeitstag im
flutgebiet rückkehr
was bleibt sind dreck und erschöpfung
und bei vielen die motivation auch am
nächsten tag wieder zu helfen
und wenn sie den menschen im
hochwassergebiet weiter helfen wollen
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
ein spendenkonto eingerichtet die bahn
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser und weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
190 und wir schauen ins ausland 82
millionen menschen sind weltweit auf der
flucht sie versuchen klimakatastrophen
armut aber vor allem krieg und gewalt zu
entkommen
besonders dramatisch ist die lage
derzeit in der äthiopischen region
3 dort bringt die zentralregierung mit
einer lokalen armee um die macht
hunderttausende menschen sind zwischen
die fronten geraten und der brutalität
von beiden seiten schutzlos ausgeliefert
salat eis beginnt bei ihren bericht in
einem flüchtlingslager weiter südlich in
der region am harrer
das also camp in der am harrer region in
äthiopien
allein hier sind knapp 2000 flüchtlinge
gestrandet viele haben schreckliches
durchgemacht sind traumatisiert
es waren hunderte ich bin auf tote
getreten als ich lief ich konnte nichts
mitnehmen
alles was ich besaß musste ich zurück
lassen rückblick im november eskaliert
der konflikt zwischen den t3 regierenden
volksbefreiungsfront von tigray tplf und
der zentralregierung von
ministerpräsident ahmed tibi schickt
unterstützt von eritrea truppen nach
trient machte die tbl es die geht zu
einem guerillakrieg über tausende werden
getötet
ende juli erobern die krayer die
regionalhauptstadt mit kehle zurück ihr
ziel ganz die drei befreien
dort ist die lage besonders dramatisch
laut un hungern hunderttausende
zehntausende seien durch die kämpfe von
monetärer hilfe abgeschnitten
die eingeschlossenen flüchtlingen
dringend lebensrettende hilfe
sauberes trinkwasser geht aus es wird
medizinische versorgung und der hunger
ist eine echte gefahr
1,7 millionen menschen sind schätzungen
zufolge durch den konflikt vertrieben
worden
das schicksal tausender ist ungewiss
hinzu kommen bericht über
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
kriegsverbrechen von sexueller gewalt
bis hin zur exekution und eine
waffenruhe ist nicht in sicht
[Musik]
menschen die flüchten haben rechte seit
genau 70 jahren sind die in der genfer
flüchtlingskonvention festgeschrieben
in unserer zdf heute app können sie
nachlesen wie es zu dem abkommen kam und
was ist den betroffenen zusichert und
sie finden dort auch ein interview mit
einer un experten zu den derzeit
drängendsten problem
unwetter mit starkregen und orkanartigen
böen diesmal im südlichen oberbayern der
landkreis rosenheim meldete heute 119
einsätze fallwinde mit orkanstärke
stürmten über die gemeinde söchtenau
hinweg viele dächer wurden abgedeckt
selbst große bäume beschädigt die
feuerwehren sind seit stunden im einsatz
auch wegen sturm und regen im
nachbarkreis traunstein und wir kommen
zur olympia und damit zu norbert und den
deutschen dressur reiterin die auf die
ist wirklich verlassen hatte das kann
zur urlaubs sagen gestern gold mit der
mannschaft heute gold und silber im
einzel wettbewerb
kleine überraschungen nicht die
siebenmalige olympiasiegerin isabell
werth stand ganz oben auf dem treppchen
sondern jessica von bredow verhandeln
die 35 jährige zeigte einen perfekten
auftritt mit der lehrer ohne patzer im
rhythmus mit der musik ein eingespieltes
team reiterin und pferd bereits das
zweite gold für jessica von bredow
werndl bei ihrem ersten olympischen
spielen mit der lehrer
bisher hatten charakter aus gold die es
unglaublich die erfolgreichste reiterin
der welt ist sie schon jetzt isabell
werth nach dem mannschafts gold holte
sie die silbermedaille auf belarus trotz
höchster schwierigkeiten zunächst
spielerisch leicht von ihrer 17 jahre
alten westfalen stute umgesetzt gab es
am ende ihrer grand prix kür kleine
patzer und somit punkte abzug
heute dass sie die nase vorne gehabt und
es ist auch keine schande mit gold und
silber nach hause zu fahren
bronze ging an die britin charlotte
dujardin
überraschungen beim judo eduard trippel
hat die silbermedaille gewonnen
der 24 jahre alte rüsselsheimer musste
sich im finale in der klasse bis 90
kilogramm dem georgischen europameister
lascher becali geschlagen geben es war
die erste deutsche männer medaille im
judo seit 2012 und sarah köhler hat die
erste olympia-medaille im becken für den
deutschen schwimm-verband seit 13 jahren
gewonnen bronze über 1500 meter freistil
am ende ko land sogar tränen die vielen
mühen haben sich gelohnt für sarah
köhler bronze auf der langstrecke mit
deutschem rekord
es ist ihr bisher größter erfolg gold
ging an katy l'equipe silber holte sich
erika sullivan beide aus den usa
[Applaus]
zittern vor der entscheidung im
synchronspringen vom drei meter brett
dann bricht es aus patrick hausding und
lars rüdiger heraus bronze lange hatte
es nicht danach ausgesehen doch ihr
letzter sprung überzeugte die
wertungsrichter einen viereinhalbfachen
salto vorwärts
gold holten die chinesen silber ging an
die us-amerikaner
klar beim olympischen radrennen der
deutsche sportdirektor patrick moster
hatte beim zeitfahren zwei fahrer
rassistisch beleidigt und dafür heftige
kritik auch aus dem deutschen verband
geerntet moster entschuldigte sich
umgehend dafür
der deutsche olympische sportbund will
zunächst keine konsequenz ziehen und
bitteres vorrunden-aus für die deutschen
olympia kicker nur 1 1 zu 1 gegen die
elfenbeinküste
trotz guter torchancen geriet das team
von trainer stefan kunz in der 67 minute
durch ein eigentor von benjamin henrichs
unglücklich in rückstand
danach gelang sogar noch der ausgleich
doch nur ein deutscher sieg hätte den
einzug ins viertelfinale bedeutet ja
noch mehr olympia sport auch heute abend
wieder im heute-journal viel anbrennen
und es ist mittwoch und da haben wir
jetzt natürlich noch die lotter zeit für
sie
die gewinnzahlen lauten 8 10 11 19 31 47
und die superzahl 3 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 57 und werfen wir
noch einen kurzen blick auf die
wetteraussichten für die meisten wird es
morgen ruhig mit sonnenschein
genaueres erfahren sie gleich von osten
telli beim heute journal um 21.45
begrüßt die bettina schausten und ich
sag auch wieder sehend machen sie es gut
[Musik]
ein so genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein hoch schiebt sich mal
zwischendurch richtung deutschland und
so wird es deutlich ruhiger werden es
gibt deutlich mehr sonnenschein morgen
im tagesverlauf nur im norden ziehen
regen und gewitter durch ein neues tief
nähert sich das wird dann von diesem
umfangreichen tief da über dem norden
dann eingefangen und so wird es dann zum
wochenende etwas kühler
schauen wir in die nachts da gibt es im
nordwesten mit dem tief schauer und
gewitter ansonsten ist es trocken vor
allem nach osten funkeln die sterne
temperaturen sinken auf 11 grad im
hessischen bergland und 16 grad zum
beispiel an der ostsee morgen im
tagesverlauf weitere schauer und
gewitter vor allem im nordwesten dazu
wird der wind stark aus südwest teils
stürmisch ja und sonst gibt es viel
sonnenschein und es ist trocken bei
temperaturen bis 27 grad im süden
deutschlands und 26 grad im osten 19 bis
20 deutlich kühler dann an der nordsee
und die nächsten tage am freitag im
süden vor allem heftige gewitter bis 27
grad
ja und das wochenende ziemlich
durchwachsen mit weiteren schauern und
gewittern und vor allem deutlich kühler
ein schöner amt